I remember there were times with the
thing I needed it would cost like fifty
dollars and it was just like it was it
was inconceivable that I could afford it
I mean like honestly Oculus owes more to
the iPhone than anything else I mean
like if the iPhone wouldn't have existed
there wouldn't have been broken iPhones
for me to buy unlock repair and sell on
eBay like because I made tens of
thousands of dollars as a teenager on
that on that side hustle like if if that
had not happened then Oculus probably
wouldn't exist today
[Music]
foreign
what's up we got Palmer lucky on the
podcast Palmer is a billionaire he
created Oculus which he sold to Facebook
he's created Andrew which is now one of
the biggest like government they make
weapons for the government and
um super interesting guy I'm gonna call
it right now I think this is a all-timer
episode I don't know what's I don't you
know you guys know I don't hype it up
like that unless it's legit this was an
all-timer episode Sam what are some of
the things that we talked about so early
on we asked them basically what he did
with his money so he made hundreds of
millions of dollars at the age of like
23 or something like that and we said
where did you put your money and it was
very clear on what he did with it uh he
talked about some of his early crypto
Investments so he bought uh crypto way
way early like in 2010 I think he said
he talked about how he was making
minimum wage and then became a
billionaire like four or five years
after just making minimum wage what else
uh we talked about a couple different
things where he likes to hang out on the
internet we're like dude
where do you how do you know about all
this stuff where do you learn this stuff
what are your subreddits what are you
what are you listening to and reading
because I need to start doing some of
that so he told us some of his foot by
the way do you remember he actually said
a Facebook group that he liked and he
actually named the Facebook group yeah
he's gonna get a lot more popular
and then
um yeah he talked about basically like
is world war three gonna happen right
he's he's supplying you know uh that his
company builds tech for the defense
department uh Department Department of
Defense and so is World War III gonna
happen is there going to be a nuke what
is a tactical nuke well you asked him a
very specific question you go is Russia
gonna drop a nuclear bomb and his
perspective is interesting I thought it
was a good question and then the best
part was we said all right you sold
Oculus and then you created Andrew which
is an even bigger success I think it's
like value to eight billion dollars or
something but there was many years in
between did you consider doing any other
ideas and he opened up and he was like
yeah actually there were these two or
three other ideas he had an idea about
uh creating a new kind of prison he had
an idea that would try to solve OB
obesity uh he had a couple ideas and we
go into depth brainstorming with him so
he had it all man he had the the crazy
backstory the success story but he also
brought ideas and then he also argued
with us about why he flies coach even
though he's a billionaire and um why he
may or may not get into a fight with
Jason calacanus and so this episode had
it all had fighting had ideas had
success stories it's got it all all
right enjoy this episode with Palmer
lucky
I don't know you don't need too much of
an intro but I'll do it anyways Palmer
lucky is here
um created Oculus created Andrew uh
really interesting dude and uh and I
think you know we have a bunch of topics
so I'm not going to kind of belabor the
intro Sam I know you've been itching we
just you probably can't say the DM you
you sent to try to get Palmer on here
you really wanted this man on the
podcast why like my first question is to
you Sam why so Palmer I am like the king
of left-handed compliments at least
that's what they say about me but I I
mean them as full-handed compliments or
right-handed compliments but basically I
love freaks I love weirdos I love
extremists not like in the political
sense but in the sense of like people
who just go all in on stuff and are just
passionate about maybe like nerdy or
unconventional things and you go all in
on things and I love that I love people
even if I don't like what they're going
going all in on I I'm crazy fascinated
by that and you see one of those guys
who just goes all in on things you
you've done a lot at a young age and I
like weirdos and I put you in that in
that category thank you I'm happy to be
happy to be a weirdo you know I'd rather
be I'd rather I'd rather be a person
that uh that that people think ill or or
or well of then somebody nobody thinks
of at all I think by the way I think
well Sam had a poster at his office that
was like for his employees he was like
Let your freak flag fly that was like
you know one of those like you know
corporate values are typically like
integrity and like determination and his
was like be a freak um all right so so
let's start with
um I don't know let's start with some of
the kind of we're gonna try to as much
we can avoid VR and avoid the Facebook
stuff because mostly just because you've
talked about it a bunch of places I'm
like frankly I'm interested because I am
actually a VR Fanboy but Sam has has
tried to forbid me from asking those
questions so we're gonna leave that at
the end if I get a little extra time but
this is a podcast that started it's
called my first million because we're
interested in money and we think it's
really funny that people are tap like
money's like you know the Silicon Valley
things you have to pretend you don't
like money and like oh I know you're
talking about yeah you know we're not
doing it here for the money you know
this money money's you know money's not
the real objective I actually tell my
own employees and onboarding that if if
you work at a place where your boss is
saying that you should be worried
because it's one thing it's one thing to
say that to the Press it's one thing to
say that in your marketing materials but
you you know if if your employees don't
believe that at the end of the day
you're trying to make their job a
fiscally responsible decision if you're
effectively telling them you could be
making more money elsewhere and your
financial success is not my priority you
should be concerned
yeah yeah exactly and you kind of did
the best of both like for all the kind
of ironic people who are like we're
trying to change the world with this
like you know HR onboarding software you
know uh you actually kind of did and
still made a bunch of money doing it so
you know it's not like an either or uh
100 I mean when I started Oculus it was
not because I thought it would be the
thing that would make the most money
there had never been a successful VR
company in history to be clear and I did
it because it was something I was really
passionate about now that said one of
the things I'm most proud of in my whole
career is that everyone who worked at
Oculus achieved Financial Independence
because we were able to build something
incredible and like I feel great that
everyone who was part of that mission
and who supported me early on was able
to make a bunch of money and then a lot
of them have gone on to do incredible
things but uh yeah Oculus was not was
not was not done because I thought it
was the best way to make money it's
because I thought it really was going to
be the best way to change the world in
the long run Android was a little
different I I that one it wasn't just oh
this will be fun I want to do something
really cool Andrew was like I felt like
I had to do it or things were things
were going to go really poorly so more
more of a more of a stick than a carrot
on that one how much did you make off
the Oculus sale oh man I probably
shouldn't say because this is also one
of those complex things where you know
there was the there was the sale so
there's what they believed they called
the merger consideration form of uh you
know portion of the of the of the uh
compensation and then they you know you
cut an employment deal where they say
we're going to pay you you know this
much for five years I can say that I was
locked I was locked up on a five-year
vesting schedule so typical would be
four most of our employees were four I
got locked up for five because I was a
key guy and uh that that money
technically is not for the acquisition
it's just yeah I had that too
um yep so yeah and of course you know
you can't you can't pretend you can't
say they're the same thing or they're
supposed to be treated differently tax
wise compensation wise and then of
course there's the bonuses we had we had
an earn out that was a it was a it was a
it was a huge earn out it was hundreds
of millions of dollars for the founders
of the company if we could hit certain
sales targets and user uh user like
hours hours of time Target chance and we
actually had four years to hit those
targets and we we hit them within less
than two years so we actually did it's
kind of funny we'll be like oh man the
acquisition must not be gone as well as
people expect it's like no we maxed out
the top bracket of our earn out uh
because we're we're kicking butt but uh
anyway it was in the hundreds of
millions of dollars I can tell you that
in the healthy hundreds of millions of
dollars what were you who listened to
this
uh sorry I'll go real quick a bunch of
people who listen to this are founders
and and like would want to sell their
company someday uh both me and Sam we
started this podcast right when we both
exited our companies because it's like
all right we're kind of earning out well
we can't start another company right now
but like oh we can start a podcast that
sounds kind of fun and um and actually
just yesterday I just closed on another
sale of a company but these are small
scale compared to what you did right
like congratulations thank you but you
you sold for I don't know two or three
billion bucks how does that happen
somebody you know Zach comes over to
your house and it's like I'll give you
three billion dollars for this like how
does that how does that even how does
that conversation go down
um when when when you're talking about
the sort of like the Grand Slam type of
outcomes well it's a it's a long story
but yeah you know I I know I know Sam
didn't want to talk all about VR but no
this shit's interesting to me oh great
then we we don't won't talk about VR
Optics and in the metaverse then but I I
guess on the business side of it the
interesting thing about the acquisition
is that we didn't have any of intention
of selling initially when we first had
our conversation with Facebook and I
think that really was a positive thing
uh because actually first time we talked
I think basically we were offered a
billion dollars to sell uh and we said
no we're not interested
we think this company's easily going to
surpass that value we think it's not
going to be a problem for us to make
more money
and uh yeah we were happy to work with
you guys but we we don't want to be by
the way was that easy to say no to a
billion dollars I mean you started this
thing like on a Kickstarter dude like
you know at some point were you like was
it hard to say no or was it not not an
issue at that point it wasn't an issue
for me and I think I think of different
people had different opinions I mean
look if you if you look over my career
I've made a lot of similar decisions
like when I was starting Oculus when I
was deciding whether I was going to do a
Kickstarter or work for someone else I
actually had a job on a job offer on the
table from uh from Sony to run a
PlayStation VR lab uh you know out of
PlayStation group and when I turned them
down they actually doubled the offer and
then I had to turn them down again and a
lot of people were wondering how could
you have done that you know how could
you have decided to do your own thing it
was so much higher risk and I think that
a lot of it is is Social programming you
know I grew up watching media that
conditioned me to believe that when you
have an opportunity you have to take it
when you know when you almost have to
follow the narrative and looking back
I'm not sure I I could have done
anything else like could I have stayed
in school instead of starting Oculus
once I realized I had this breakthrough
in VR technology I think I could not
have possibly done it there's it it's
almost to the level of free will not
existing I could not have chosen that
could I have gone and worked for Sony
looking back I don't think so I think I
couldn't have made that decision and I
think it's actually the same thing with
that billion dollar offer like I almost
could not have said yes you know like
that that first offer like narratively
it makes no sense it doesn't align with
what I've been trained as what you do
when you're uh you know when you're a
free thinking iconoclast and so I
couldn't have done it I think what what
happened is a few things changed over
over time after that initial offer you
know we didn't talk to Facebook for for
a few months after that and a few things
happened one it became clear that our
competition was not only serious but was
going to be putting massive dollars into
their success something not a lot of
people remember uh but I certainly do
because you it was a big deal in my mind
the day that we announced no the day we
find it wasn't anything else the day we
finalized the Facebook acquisition was
the same day that Sony announced
PlayStation VR and we had known that it
was coming for a while we we actually
even shown each other prototypes and
stuff but it really reinforced this was
a serious thing we're gonna have some of
the biggest games companies in the world
putting hundreds of millions of dollars
into competing with us and uh you know
that that made I think our that made the
the pitch that Facebook came back with
which is listen you maybe you could make
more money as an independent company but
if you're with us we're going to make VR
happen much faster so it you yes you
might make more money but you're going
to go much slower than if we were able
to artificially supercharge your growth
far beyond even what you could do with
venture capital and they they were
willing to commit billions of dollars a
year for a period of a decade or more
and that's that's a really tough thing
to turn down when you really believe in
something and is this like literally
Zuck coming to your house and talking
about this or is there like an army of
lawyers in between you guys that are
like you know bankers and and Corp Dev
people it was a very small number of
people I mean it was it was I mean I I
think that the the the the lawyers and
the accountants are much more likely to
be involved in a deal when the deal is
contingent on uh you know your revenue
and your multiples and your P L's like
that that's where you need to drag those
people in to really make a an assessment
this was such a high level bet it's not
like oh I think that you have this
margin on your headset and you've sold
this many development kits it was so
early and the technology so nascent the
real bet is do you believe in the
metaverse do you believe that there's
going to be a virtual world parallel to
our own where you're living and you're
working you're playing and then most
importantly do you believe this is the
best team in the world to do it and I
didn't know this at the time but I found
out later that Mark had been going
around and talking to various uh
University Research Labs Government
research Labs talking to you know seeing
what other companies were doing and
their conclusion was we were way ahead
of everyone else and that if if this was
going to happen this shift to immersive
Computing the final Computing platform
arguably that we were the people in the
best position to do it and that's not
something that a lawyer can really give
an opinion on it's not something that an
accountant can put a value on it's it's
a very high level bet
what was your personal financial
situation when you turned down the
billion dollar offer so at the time uh
early early in Oculus so yeah I mean I
started Oculus using my own money and at
that time I was working a minimum wage
job and living in a 19-foot camper
trailer I was 19 years old so for people
who aren't familiar with the story to
that degree I mean I had almost no money
literally had a few hundred dollars in
my bank account because I spent all the
money that I made putting myself through
school and working on virtual reality
technology and I was extraordinarily and
I had a minimum wage job I was also
fixing computers on the side for a while
I'd been buying broken iPhones but
fixing them and unlocking them selling
those for spare cash and so I I burned a
lot of money on my on my on my nutty
hobby
um and when we started Oculus uh we we
didn't pay ourselves very much by the
time the acquisition happened I had
given myself a raise we decided that
nobody in the company was going to make
over a hundred thousand dollars we
called it the 100K Club so we're paying
the CEO a hundred thousand dollars uh I
was getting paid a hundred thousand
dollars and uh to me that that actually
felt incredible I was like Wow hundred
thousand dollars this is absolutely
crazy I can I can afford anything you're
like you know how many cell phones how
many iPhones I'd have to fix to make a
hundred thousand dollars a lot because
you were fixing iPhones and like
scrubbing boats or something I read is
yeah I mean when I started working on VR
stuff I was I I worked for a few years
in a boat yard so yeah scrubbing boats
repainting repainting the the the the
the bottom paint uh sweeping the boat
yard you know that that type of stuff
um so so to me the money was not was not
a huge motivating factor also because
maybe maybe too optimistically I
believed Oculus was going to be worth
tens of billions or hundreds of billions
of dollars so it really wasn't the the
month I know this is what contrary to
what I said before but it wasn't the
money that was motivating me to make the
sale the it was the pitch hey we're
gonna get you billions of dollars right
now like not not the not the
compensation for the for the for the
acquisition but we're going to give you
your your organization billions of
dollars a year to go out and make
virtual reality actually happen and
that's what you're going to need to
compete with Google to compete with Sony
to compete with Microsoft all of which
have seen what you're doing bought in
like they've drunk your Kool-Aid but
they're gonna try to kill you over it uh
that that was kind of the situation we
were were in and Facebook was one of the
very few companies that had a strong
incentive to make virtual reality and
immersive Computing writ large to come
about as quickly as possible because
unlike Google unlike Microsoft they did
not benefit from the status quo in the
hardware space so if we kept using
mobile phones and normal computers for
you know that 20 30 years Google and
Microsoft are going to do just fine like
they're already the winners in that
Paradigm if you can shake everything up
and force a reset with immersive
Computing AR VR Mr whatever you want to
call it uh it could be that Microsoft is
one of the top players and it could be
that Apple and Google are are some of
the top players but it's unlikely that
all of them are going to remain the
dominant players and that's an opening
for a company like Facebook to come in
and even if they're not first place
forcing the reset puts them in second or
third place instead of being totally
subservient to the operating system uh
vendors and to the hardware vendors so
it was one of those things where there
were other companies that were
interested none of them actually had a
strong incentive to put billions of
dollars into VR on an ongoing Basin I
mean you can see Google killed their VR
program first they killed their pcvr
team then they killed their mobile VR
team Microsoft is winding down their
internal efforts I mean it's a it's a
it's a it's a tough business and I'm not
convinced that Oculus would still be
around if we hadn't had those resources
I'm gonna uh move on from like asking
you these money questions but I want to
ask one more because I do think it's
fascinating because you went from like
maybe not having a lot to having a lot
and you're also like an eyeball yeah
which I like when I sold my business I
put everything into bonds and just
Vanguard Total index funds and just did
like a normal 80 20 split and then
eventually some real estate and then
HubSpot stock and just normal like basic
stuff what did you do with your money
and what have you because I know you
bought like a a marina I think or you
tried to buy it I don't know if it went
through uh but like what what does like
someone like you do with that amount of
uh liquidity so most of it I did what
you're talking about I generally don't
believe in trying to beat the market
through Market Market transactions I
mean it's one thing to build like I
think you build wealth by building
companies that's where you should be
focusing your effort not trying to be
smarter than all the finance guys
who are sitting around and using every
tool at their disposal
to try and game the financial market so
actually yeah Vanguard funds like
Vanguard 500 total index funds
um my grandpa taught me a lot about
investing and about how you shouldn't
try to beat the market probably the the
my investment philosophies informed
mostly by John bogle's little black book
on investing where he's like look you
know keep your fees low keep your costs
low and just go with the market and you
know if the market goes so poorly that I
become poorer then the United States has
bigger problems than uh than than than
the market
um so that was that was most what I did
I bought the marina not as a financial
investment it was actually it was one of
the only marinas so this is getting a
little into the Weeds on something
probably very few people care about but
just so you know
um in California almost all marinas the
water is owned by the state or by the
feds and then they do long-term leases
like 30 or 40 years to operators that
are allowed to operate those marinas and
they might own let's say the parking lot
the operator but they do not own the
water they do not own the stocks it's
just a long-term lease and they redo
that over there's only a small handful
of marinas in the entire State of
California where the underlying land
under the water and the water itself is
deeded to a private title and the marina
that I bought was one of those and uh
you know without getting into without
getting into my my whole seasteading
delusion I think that you're going to
end up needing uh if you want to have
transport ferries that are operating
from Land out to international waters
you do not want to be in a position
where the place you're doing that from
is totally dependent on state government
bureaucrats choosing to renew your lease
on a particular on a particular Marina
so that was actually that was actually a
purchase that'll it'll it'll pay off
someday uh you'll see you all see
see I bought my house just like I like
the walk-in closet was nice and I was
like oh that's a good enough reason for
me I didn't have to like you know go
into international waters uh to make it
all in my case I I did buy I mean I did
I did a few things like as soon as I had
money I immediately started learning to
fly helicopters for real because I'd
always wanted to be a helicopter pilot
ever since being a little kid so like it
was like it was like two weeks after the
wire completed I was I was flying
helicopter so that was really cool
um I bought a 69 Mustang convertible
that was really cool and uh I bought a
first generation Tesla Model S that was
cool and then I bought a house for my
parents you know it's like the the it's
like the basketball player contract move
you know you you get the money you buy
the you buy the house for for your
parents and then I bought a house for
myself that was close to my grandpa
actually uh and unfortunately we then
ended up having to move up to Silicon
Valley because of the acquisition and
then he passed away while I was up there
so one one of my one of my regrets but
I'm still in that house
wow uh okay that's amazing and uh one
other thing I had seen was that you I
don't know if this is even a real thing
or it's like some
Twitter fake you know fake photo or
whatever did you buy Bitcoin in 2013 no
no I bought Bitcoin much earlier than
that
2013 is when I was on I I was in the
Forbes 30 under 30 and they asked
everyone on it for a quote for the print
edition and it was the theme was what is
your advice to other young Founders and
my quote was buy more Bitcoin
um but I I've actually been involved in
Bitcoin since before there were any
exchanges I like I I was a true OG on
the bitcoinetalk.org forums there were
no exchanges you could only do direct
transactions for goods I actually sold a
banner ad on my game console
modification Forum it was a one week
Banner ad on this forum with almost no
traffic and I sold it for 400 Bitcoin uh
and then I ended up uh I ended up buying
someone's uh Samsung Samsung Galaxy
Vibrant which was the T-Mobile variant
of the first Galaxy phone uh for 800
Bitcoin I believe uh which at the time
was you know well well under a dollar
per Bitcoin right so I I've actually
been in 16 million very early days 16 oh
my God how do you huh so like all right
you you we had biology you know biology
uh on the Pod and like he was one of
these guys where he would like give an
analogy he was like oh you know Bitcoin
is kind of like the Battle of tames and
I'm like bro I you can't you I needed an
analogy for your analogy like I can't
tell you about the Battle of teams in
World War II like I can't have that
conversation with you and you're a
little bit like that where you're
talking about like uh you just like
threw in a few lines like all this
gaming Forum I have when I was like well
I could go down that path but then
you're talking about like this boat
marina thing and I'm like that's a whole
conversation like how on Earth do you
discovered that and then I'm sure you
have strong opinion you just have a a
very sh and then now obviously you're
doing government stuff then you've done
uh and you know a bunch about politics
whatever how are you becoming so
well-versed and also so opinionated on
such a broad set of topics
because you have to most of the time
like the best things that I've done that
I have done in my career have not been
going super super deep on one vertical
and then finding the really really hard
gains that are at the end of a long
fight that everyone's made like an
example here would be uh with just like
Optics technology most people are
fighting way at the end of the spectrum
where they're trying to like oh we're
using new Cutting Edge materials that
increase the ability to control light
more precisely by two percent and we're
trying to figure out the physics of how
we can manufacture these polymers most
of my best ideas have not come from that
they've been from knowing things in
totally different fields that have
nothing to do with the field or at least
people don't think they do and then
pulling ideas from those fields and
applying them in a new way like the the
really key thing that made the oculus
rift work is just one example rather
than focusing on trying to make these
Optical Stacks that cost thousands of
dollars and weighed a bunch and that was
really what was making these headsets
way many pounds and cost tens of
thousand dollars it was the high-end
Optical stack that was able to project
images on your retina with minimal
Distortion but you needed you know a
bunch of lenses they're all very very
expensive very high Precision what I did
is figure out that you could just render
a distorted image basically render your
image distort it on the graphics card uh
in the inverse way that the lens
distorted it and then basically you
would render an image that looks
terrible on the screen but after viewing
it through the lens that I had which was
optimized for high field of view low
weight low cost but not optimized have
low Distortion low chromatic aberration
or geometric aberration it would come
out looking looking perfect and like
that that's something where an optical
engineer someone who's working on just
Optics would not would not think of that
you know that's very much like a a a
software idea but the software people
are also not necessarily thinking about
how they could obsolesce expenses
expensive pieces of Optics and of course
there are people who do that do that I
think that some of the best
entrepreneurs are people who have on
understanding that is sufficient in
enough areas to pull from one area and
solve the biggest problems of another so
I I mean I I make it a priority you
asked how do I do it you make it a
priority to know a little about a lot so
uh two questions one just go back to the
Bitcoin thing for a second sure how did
you get into like why were you on the
Bitcoin talk forums or why did you see
it even before you know almost anybody
uh so what were you doing there and why
did it catch your eye
um and then you know today 10 years
later there's a whole bunch of people
that are disillusioned by it they say oh
it's all this time's gone by 10 years
didn't work out other people are more
bullish than ever you know where do you
stand now so what caught your eye and
where do you stand now so I mean I think
I got into Bitcoin it would have been
mid mid to late 2010
um and and I I I was really fascinated
because I I mean look I'm a guy who was
into virtual reality in the metaverse
this is just adjacent to that it's
another super cool you know cyberpunk
con except the idea of you know uh
untraceable internet currency that is
based on only the consensus of all of
the cyberpunks who are using it
cryptographically verified and secured
with no nation-state controlling it or
issuing it or diluting it or
manipulating like like what what a cool
thing when you're when you're an
anti-authority teenager who who loves
who loves cyberpunk science fiction
um and so that that it was like I bought
into the the very original cool Vision
not the oh this is going to be huge for
everybody one but like this is this is
this is cyberpunk Incarnate I have to be
a part of this
um and when I started uh like my initial
thinking was not that it was a good
store of value that was that's actually
been I think the most contentious
thing about crypto is after it started
Skyrocket I didn't buy it because I was
speculating nobody was even thinking
about that back then like it's it's
crazy to me to watch all these new
crypto kids get in and it seems like
it's all about just having having coins
pumping the value dumping them it's
really just you know these this
financial markets play that I've never
believed in because I always believe in
you know investing in the whole Market
um but to me it was always value as a as
a means of moving wealth around it's not
as a store for years or decades it's a
way that you can move wealth around uh
without any without being beholden to
any any centralized Authority or
centralized power and I think today like
even for all the issues Bitcoin has and
people you know putting it down because
of it crashing well first of all every
time there's a Bitcoin crash it's like
oh no it's crash two only 10x what it
was two years ago every single time
every crash is like that
um but more importantly it's still a
good way to move value around and uh
that said my prediction in 2013 was that
Bitcoin will go to about a hundred
thousand dollars and then stabilize I'm
sticking with it I I think I think it'll
get there I'm not I'm not sure that it
in particular has the has the
appropriate utility to reach a higher
store of value
and wow okay amazing and then did you oh
by the way I have and I have to throw
out there I'm one of those guys who lost
a bunch of coins in the mount goxack oh
man I got gox good
um and it was it was one of those things
where there was no like looking back
everyone's like oh my God I can't
believe that you know you would have and
I had most of my coins in in my own
wallet uh but I had a significant amount
on on gox because people were
transferring coins to my God to my docs
account and uh now everyone's like oh my
god of course you would never keep your
coins in an exchange but like I was 16
years old and like you know there was
there was no there's no like idiot's
guide to bitcoin back then it was it was
the type of thing you only used if you
were a crazy A crazy internet Nutter and
so you've mentioned forums and I'm a big
Forum sky like I still I remember you
know BB I wasn't like before whatever
was before BBS that's not me but I've
been on forums and I love forums and you
talked about amen the Bitcoin talk
forums I went and read a bunch of your
early posts on the what was the name of
the like odd retro no no no the the
headset one that had TBS 3D yeah exactly
your old post there I went and like
stalked him just to be like because I
like to see the origin oh my God it's
fun like what are the like
archaeologists for like the internet I
like to go find the original and so
um you know I saw you posting there and
you're like hey I'm trying to build this
thing I'm thinking about doing this you
did a bunch of like kind of really cool
crowdsource stuff I think you even like
asked read it like you know should I buy
should we buy Vive or something like
that you did a bunch of cool stuff on
forums and I thought about that and some
of them like I when I learned poker I
learned it through forums yep if you
think about today like if who's the
secret the 16 year old version of you
today what forums do you think they're
hanging out in what's the thing because
when you were doing this is 15 years ago
like we are still early and you were
early early same thing with Bitcoin you
were early early and so what do you
think are the interesting forums today
that people are hanging out in that you
think will play out over the next decade
or so and and also what are what are
what are some of your favorite pockets
of the web and and forums that you're
hanging out in I mean much to my chagrin
I like I love forums too I think they
are more or less the Pinnacle of
asynchronous communication like if you
are doing collaborative products all of
the incentives are correct like so so I
like I I ran a forum the mod retro
forums it was a forum for people who
modified vintage game consoles in
particular with a focus on turning them
into handheld self-contained units so
cutting apart Nintendo 64s and super
Nintendos and PlayStations and then
replacing like the Power Electronics
with modern Power Electronics running
them off of the latest lithium battery
technology although it was nikad back
when back when I started started you
know working on Portables uh you know
putting in LCD screens that were
designed for portable DVD players and
the like and building these
self-contained units and uh it the
forums are interesting because your your
currency is is attention but you can
only get attention by getting people to
come in and you know respond and engage
with you and so there's a strong
incentive to update people on what
you're doing to to write really
interesting things and to you know get
people regularly coming back and
engaging with your stuff I mean that's
the dopamine high right it's other
people care about what I'm doing today
it's been so algorithm you know
algorithmically driven that you don't
have the same incentives in terms of
long-term sustained engagement and uh
you know collaborating with people
there's a lot more incentive to do
things on your own do one big push in a
form that will cause ordinary people who
are not necessarily technically
competent to you know watch it for at
least three minutes so that it's seen as
you watch it long enough and I like I
think the pockets which is what you
asked like there's great pockets on
YouTube there's great pockets on Reddit
there's actually a lot of private
Facebook groups uh so like one highlight
like I'm a member of a of a Night Vision
Group where people build their own night
vision night vision goggles and it's got
a couple thousand people but it's it's a
private group and very very much not
virally driven uh you know it's not like
the tick tock tick tock techno heads
it's not like the YouTube techno heads
but man I I really miss forums you know
mod retro we had a core group of a few
thousand active members that were that
were doing stuff in the Heyday and we
were doing a few a few million page
views a month uh and you would you never
see those ratios these days you know of
of of
engagers to to to Watchers one thing
that um that uh I thought was actually
really interesting I don't know I've
interrupt I have to interrupt one last
thing I forgot
um actually a huge fraction of the
people that I hired for Oculus in the
early days were volunteer moderators on
The Mod retro forums like people always
you know they hire their Network right
they hire the people that they know that
they can trust and that they know are
competent and that was my network when I
was a teenager it was other it was other
loser gamer teenagers on the internet
and so we like that like we some of our
lead electrical people our lead Hardware
people our lead mechatronics people uh
we're all people who had been moderators
on mod retro in fact the first person I
hired for Oculus was was one of the
other moderators and I I actually uh
sent him a message said hey what are you
doing uh what are you doing what are you
doing this fall and he said oh I'm I'm
starting starting College I said no
you're not you're gonna come work for me
and I literally I like I told him that
on a Friday and I literally drove out in
my minivan to pick him up from his mom's
house on Monday and he had all his stuff
in like four boxes and I picked him up
we got in my van and we drove to The
Condemned motel that I was living in I
mean it was it was it was wild I mean
that and that that was that was my
network so it's always funny when people
are like oh you know your network is
your net worth you know look yeah we're
you got all the stand for kids you got
the ivy kids and we were just a bunch of
Internet losers and we did better than
any of them you're like um I'm hiring
hmd alumni they're like oh is that
Harvard Medical no no head mounted
display Forum alumni
actually the guy that I was hiring uh is
his name is Chris dycus and he had never
built a head mounted display but he was
he was very accomplished on these
horribleizing scene
consoles and I knew he was very
competent I knew exactly like you talk
about a job interview where you meet
someone for you know whatever they're
you know maybe an hour or something but
I had been seeing this guy's work
published on the Forum over the course
of years and so I knew he had I knew he
had skills and I knew he had work that's
exactly we me and Sean have hired so
many people on Twitter and I tell people
all the time like I want to get a job
I'm like man if you just like you need
to post your thoughts so people
understand your texture and your tastes
and your character like that is
significantly better doing it there and
then just dming someone and then they're
just gonna click their profile oh this
person's tweeting all this like
interesting Insight that aligns exactly
well and that's harder to fake too if
you if you have somebody who has a
history of building things for
themselves of doing things because they
want to not because they're getting paid
to that you can't fake that the way that
you can fake an interview it's easy like
oh I'm passionate about X Y and Z well
show me your years of work that you've
done for no money showing that you
really are and I mean we we still hire a
lot of people like that at Andrew like
uh we we have benefits that are intended
to lure people like that like one of our
benefits we have is that we will buy
anyone in the company any tool they want
for their personal projects as well as
work projects and that's the type of
thing where people who don't have
personal projects who just you know they
show up to their to their wage machine
and they clock in and they clock out
they're not attracted by that but the
types of people who want to create for
the sake of creation those to those
people that's a golden ticket on that
note we did the same thing my co-founder
he's a lot like you like 15 at age 15
started working at a.com during the.com
boom it was like you know had a job and
it was like what the hell is going on
and always was just doing his own thing
and so he used to buy
um like 3D printers and Robotics and
we're building like social apps it's
like we didn't need any of this stuff
and I was like what are you doing like
why are we doing this he's like because
hey I want it like I want to come to a
space and like when I'm done with work
I'm just gonna go downstairs to their
lab and I'm gonna build like a drone or
I'm gonna like take this Raspberry Pi
and like shove it over here and figure
something out out and he's like also
that's also how we'll get great people
like I want to work with other hackers
like that who like to Tinker on this
stuff and he's like he's like he's like
he had had an exit so he's like you know
doing very well his last company went
public and so he was like you know when
I was like 16 18 21 like I just couldn't
afford to like the thousand dollar thing
that you would need to have he's like I
just got lucky that the dude down the
street would let me come over and play
with his thing and that's like that was
like a a life changer of a moment he's
like so I just want to do that for
people like I just make it free anybody
can come in and anybody can use this
stuff and he was totally right even
though like our CFO was like hey we
can't justify this he's like don't worry
I'll pay for it all out of pocket and it
was like and I know and I know that
struggle you know what like and it
doesn't even have to be a thousand
dollars I mean I remember there were
times where the thing I needed it would
cost like fifty dollars and it was just
like it was it was inconceivable that I
could afford it I mean like honestly
Oculus owes more to the iPhone than
anything else I mean like if the iPhone
phone wouldn't have existed there
wouldn't have been broken iPhones for me
to buy unlock repair and sell on eBay
like because I made tens of thousands of
dollars as a teenager on that on that
side hustle like if if that had not
happened then Oculus probably wouldn't
exist today that's amazing I want to um
ask you a bit about Andrew but before
before we get to that what ideas were
you pursuing or uh I bet you if you're
like us I imagine you have a list of
like things that you're contemplating
what was what was on that list uh prior
to starting Android I know there was
like a prison thing and but what what
else like were you interested in well
what was the prison thing let's start
with that one because that one sounds
interesting also there were two things I
was seriously considering and then one
thing that I'm I'm gonna do someday so
see studying is off the table right now
it's too long term but there were two
short-term things that I was looking at
uh aside from Android so the three
choices were fixed National Security
solve obesity or solve
incarceration uh and yeah I tried to
think about you know what are the ways
that I would tackle these issues and the
way I solved defense was I wanted to
build a defense Products company that
upends the incentives that typically
exist in the military-industrial complex
but the prison one was that I wanted to
basically take out the incentives of the
private Prison Complex that exists today
right now private prison companies are
are growing there's more and more people
being housed in privately operated
prisons they're publicly traded and
those companies have a strong incentive
to lobby for and and perpetuate laws
that incarcerate people for the longest
period of time for the least serious
crime in other words they don't want
murderers and terrorists they want they
want non-violent drug offenders who will
be in prison for a long time and when
they get out of prison they want them to
come back and be a repeat customer they
want good good tenants they want good
occupancy good tenants and and the
incentives they've set up with the
government where the government pre-pays
for these beds the government basically
says well we've already paid for the bed
so if they're not full then we're not
locking up enough people it's a very bad
set of incentives so my idea was that I
could start a private prison company
that would run as a non-profit
organization and we would use the tax
advantages of that to out-compete
private prison companies and more
importantly we would have a business
model that would incent everybody
towards the right set of incentives so
what I wanted to do is go to the
government and say listen I'll lock up
your prisoners but you don't get to pay
us up front in fact you can't pay us up
front you have to pay us after the
person serves their term and then stays
out of prison for five years then you're
going to pay me and the idea is that now
all of a sudden I'm motivated and EV my
whole organization is motivated to get
people through as quickly as possible
release them as quickly as possible and
then have them stay out of prison and
not return to crime and I mean that
would have been that would have been a
game changer and it would have been a
very attractive business model to these
governments that are always you know
looking to delay their expenditures the
biggest problem that I ran into as I
looked into this is it wasn't a
technological problem it was a lobbying
and marketing and government Affairs
problem and it wasn't at a federal level
where you can basically convince a
handful of people and then achieve
success it was going to be this like
this Locale by Locale thing where you
have a lot of people who depend on
prisons for jobs you have a lot of
politicians who are very involved in it
was and also the deals are not
recompeted very often this isn't like
Enterprise software where people are
always on the lookout for a way to get
an edge or move to a new provider that
could reduce their costs or risk it's
like oh yeah we're going to recompete
this deal in 35 years and so it would
have been this thing where I I just
couldn't have made an impact fast enough
and so I've been involved with other
people who are making impacts in other
ways okay so that was one well you
couldn't just have like some Silicon
Valley guy wearing like tight jeans and
brown shoes like every other sale
salesperson sitting down like hey so
we'd like to have a conversation about
your prisoners we'd like to have your
business like you know give me some of
your unfortunately not uh yeah yeah
unfortunately not and the thing is the
people who make the decisions uh would
not have benefited from us succeeding so
in business like when you're and this is
a big we can get into this with Andrew
too one of the biggest problems with
selling to the government versus uh
businesses or private private
individuals with with private
individuals and businesses you just have
to convince them that uh it'll be it'll
be a you know that that'll be a good
thing for them and then they'll buy them
the people who are in charge of
purchasing for government they often
don't benefit from saving money or
reducing their Manpower or any of this
thing in many cases the guy in charge of
making the buying decision is political
power and earning power are directly
tied to his ability to keep costs high
and to keep Manpower up and to not allow
anything to displace that so that was
actually the big problem I realized that
it's it's nice to think you can solve
any problem with with new ideas through
disruption but some things are kind of
self-reinforcing very hard to fix the
the other thing I was looking at is
obesity you know obesity is uh is one of
if not the leading preventable cause of
death in the United States uh either
there's so many there's so many other
health problems that are the result of
obesity and some people say that we need
to make exercise more popular some
people say that we need to stop
normalizing obesity some people say we
need medical treatment for it or we need
to make eat healthy eating better I took
a pretty cynical view of it I said no
obesity is not going away unless you let
American people
eat whatever they want whenever they
want as much as they want with no
Lifestyle Changes no exercise and
absolutely no effort on their parts
whatsoever and So within that constraint
what could you do to to solve this issue
and uh the the the result the the idea I
came on was uh long chain hydrocarbon
based synthetic food so in other words
oil-based Foods uh you guys are familiar
with impossible Burger Beyond Burger
have you had them yeah yeah
so I mean it was probably better than
the worst beef burger you've ever had
right it was at least at that level it's
better than the worst one you've ever
had yeah it was a whatever I'll eat this
yeah whatever really it is but certainly
not up to the level of the best beef
burger you've ever had no
and and so one of the one of the
interesting this is where I was drawing
from outside you know an outside world
all these people trying to make fake
food they're all trying to build fake
food out of food and I said well wait
let's think of this from first
principles if I'm a materials engineer
and I'm trying to solve the set of
problems that a fake Burger manufacturer
is trying to solve you know how it feels
in your mouth how it comes apart in your
mouth how it how it Sears how it Cooks
how it changes texture when it's cooked
if I was a chemical or material engineer
trying to build let's say it's not food
just us you know a paste a substance
with a certain set of of parameters what
am I going to use is it is it beans is
it chickpeas is it corn no of course not
I'm going to use oil because man is a
master of oil we can make it in anything
waxes gels solids anything in between
rubbers pastes we can do anything with
oil we can make it into truly anything
with almost any material properties that
we want and so I said well let's
leverage that let's leverage everything
we know about making inert hydrocarbons
that are non-toxic and use that to make
fake food for people that tastes and
feels like real food but has zero
caloric value that cannot be absorbed by
your body it just goes right through you
just like fiber and this is not that
crazy Taco but Diet Coke for uh yeah
yeah that exists dude it's called The
White Castle uh but you're I mean yeah
you're just saying like the diet coke
cheeseburger yes Diet Coke cheeseburger
the diet coke cheese the diet you know
the the diet coke dairy products and so
I actually started making prototypes of
this and I was messing around with uh
frying foods and mineral oil uh with
with high flash points because mineral
oil also no calories I made some
paraffin based cheese so it's basically
like paraffin wax based fake cheese
product that you could still make
grilled cheese sandwiches with and it
tasted great but at almost no calories
um it was there were a few other wild
things that came with I also built a
device that injected uh soda syrup
through a stream onto your tongue
directly as carbonated water flowed over
it because it turns out you can only
detect it's a weird perceptual thing
people think of optical illusions as as
you know the the main type of Illusion
that's out there but there's also
physical Illusions like if you if you
put putting in your mouth your body
assumes that the full mass of the
pudding is comprised of whatever is
touching your tongue but if you can
create a physically structured Foods
where the part that's touching your
tongue is different than the bulk of the
rest of the material your body still
thinks that the entire bulk of it is
whatever's touching your tongue anyway
dude
for a while what does your house look
like
well I mean it it's a little more boring
now
um but at the time uh when when I was
acquired by Facebook I moved up to the
Bay area and we had about 10 people
living in a 13 000 square foot home that
was built in the 30s on six acres and so
we turned the dining room into a machine
shop we turned uh we we turned the there
was like a like a ballroom for dancing
and we turned that into an assembly area
and and and Welding welding room I mean
we had a soft goods room in a sunny area
as someone does it was true I don't even
know what that means what are soft goods
that was just like um so like cream
cheese
I mean like the traditional example when
people talk like a soft goods engineer
would be like uh like tennis shoes bras
um uh you know things that are
incorporating fabrics and also apply or
think you know like uh like a tennis a
tennis racket is is is an example of
soft good engineering where you've got
you know the handle and the shock
absorption and all that but in our case
it was for head mounted display stuff um
so like head mounted display straps the
fat the fabric associated with it um we
also were you know we're also cosplayers
so we were also building our building
our anime costumes there so a lot of
soft good stuff the more you talk the
more I realize you uh you do the one
thing that we celebrate the most on this
podcast because they're like people are
like I don't get it like you and Sam you
do a certain style of Entrepreneurship
right for example I optimize for just I
want it to be me and one other dude I
don't want any employees I don't want to
go to an office and I just want Max
leverage and I'm not trying to be a
billionaire I don't want to raise money
I want to own the whole thing and just
do it my way on whatever projects are
fun and um but then sometimes we'll
celebrate like the you and Elon Musk of
the world that are going huge and
sometimes we celebrate this dude who's
making this Chrome extension he makes
20K a month and lives in you know Bali
and he's having fun and so people don't
get it they're like what do you respond
do you admire like I get it TechCrunch
admires this thing and VCS admire this
thing but you guys seem to be across the
board and we're like we like people that
just Define the win Define winning on
their terms and then like actualize it
so like you having a house with 13 other
people that does that has like you know
an assembly room and a soft goods room
and whatever it seems like you're living
your best life in that state maybe 100
the weird thing about what I get to do
now like these these all sound you know
like like fun things but I'm still
getting to do that and like Android we
have all kinds of stuff like that going
on actually the the tough thing is the
coolest things that we're doing here I
can't even necessarily talk about
because the most successful projects
that are doing the cooling going in the
coolest directions are the ones that
that we have to keep kind of uh on wraps
oh I have to say on petroleum food just
in case anyone's wondering why I didn't
do that
um one I thought National Security would
would be a better use of my time and
that was because I realized uh Tech was
that National Security was a
technological problem in addition to
being a lobbying and marketing problem
and sales problem
um the the problem with petroleum Foods
is that it was not sustainable if using
new oil as a feedstock
um it would just it would consume too
much uh and the good news is you can
recycle hydrocarbons but then I mean if
you I don't know if you can see where
this is going but it means you're going
to literally be like centrifuging oil
out of of the sewer system and then
reusing it to construct new food and I
realized have you seen all the media
coverage of Pinks pink slime at
McDonald's and that's just like I saw it
but it looks kind of gross
do you think people want to buy food
that's literally remanufactured from
sewage you know that that was kind of
the main problem I said you know what
I'm I'm pretty good at marketing and
sales I am not good enough to sell sewer
food to people yeah you you sound I need
to figure that out you sound like you're
a bad guy in Batman if you're like yeah
he's going through the sewers and
recycling it turning it into food
it's like it's almost too good of a
story right like like I under sometimes
I think the media is unfair but it's
like could you expect them to not you
know sensationalize literally a guy
who's who's selling reprocessed sewage
as food like it's like they have to
cover it in a sensational way and I
can't even blame them for it and I
decide I would rather work in an area
where technological Improvement
would be the main way that you would
compete we didn't need to you know do
crazy marketing you just had to be
competent and be better than all of the
other players which was not necessarily
that high of a bar
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
do you uh you talked about the media for
a second and I when I was doing research
I was like you know there's this great
Silicon Valley Post that's called like
the hands of time of social media of of
media in Silicon Valley it's like it
starts at noon and it's like you're born
you know nobody's ever heard of you then
at one you're like emerging at three
you're like the star everybody loves you
and it like goes and then it Cycles all
the way back to midnight and it's like
you're evil uh you're ruining society
and you like destroy democracy and
whatever else and this happens with
every hot company and every hot founder
whatever and when I was looking at your
media coverage to do research it's all
like this is the boy wonder he's 19
years old he's making virtual reality
real he's doing this out of his Garage
in his house or whatever and then it
turns into like this guy is like you
know the Maga super evil guy he's
getting fired by Facebook and then it's
like the defense stuff so you've seen
kind of both sides of the media machine
does that make you kind of jaded like
where do you trust the media today and
like how do you think about you know the
media well there's an interesting quote
that people often misuse from the Nolan
Batman movies uh
you either die a hero or live see
yourself live long enough to become the
villain and a lot of people
misunderstand that they think that it
means you start out as a hero and then
eventually descend into into being uh
you know a bad guy and they look at
Harvey Dent and they they think that's
the moral but that's not what was what
what Harvey Dent was saying Harvey Dent
had actually always been a kind of
crooked power seeking political type
what what he was saying is that he had
always been the same person fighting for
the same ideals and that he just lived
long enough to see the world change
around him that so that people started
saying that what he was was a villain
you know he didn't say that you become
the villain used literacy to see
yourself become the villain in the eyes
of everyone else and I I feel like I've
definitely been through been through
that uh been through that a little bit I
mean it's worth noting I'm not inclined
to dislike the media naturally a lot of
people assume that that must be the case
I I don't know if you know this I was a
journalism major at Cal State Long Beach
I was actually the online editor of the
of the school paper the daily 49er so I
I by no meat like there was a time where
I thought I was going to go into a
career in Tech journalism and so I I
never really had had any issues with it
um as a as you know I thought it was a
very a very honorable thing to do you
know to go out and be the guy who dig
digs and gets the truth and lets people
know what's going on that they otherwise
would not have the ability or the time
to suss out themselves uh and then
unfortunately I've had quite a few
experiences with the media it's like do
I trust the media it's like well I mean
I've had like literally dozens of major
Outlets post literally fabricated quotes
from me uh literally literally like
things that never happened uh they said
they all we did all these terrible
things that just never even happened and
then refused to correct them for years
on end so it's one of those people like
oh Palmer why do you attack the media
it's like I don't know like there's not
any real way to to get to get around
this I mean like we're not talking about
tiny Outlets like the New York Times
posted a quote for me that I literally
never said and I I told them like hey
you you said that I said this I never
said that they said well it's it's it's
it's more or less what you said we don't
think the meeting is different and I was
like yeah but your your ethics guide I
know I know what it is I was taught the
New York Times style guide when I was in
journalism school it doesn't it doesn't
say you get to quote me and paraphrase
me and you think that it is it doesn't
mean anything different and then of
course everyone re-quotes their fake
quote you're like I don't think a quote
means what you think it means you know
you're like those those like you know
those little signs in the paper that say
it's a quote that means something
different than what than what you guys
are saying well I explained to them I
said I said your quote for me is
literally missing six of the words that
I said but you have it in quotes with a
period And I I never said that
um and it was actually it was there was
no period because it was part of a
longer run-on argument I was making that
that did not even have a period there
and they're like oh well we don't think
it really changes the meaning so just
without belaboring the point uh I think
you you can't you can't trust the media
to to uh you can't trust the media to do
the right thing and if you do you're
probably gonna get burned at some point
it worked for me for a while uh until it
didn't what does um what does Andrew do
and what made you realize that the the
the the approach to solve that problem
was the approach that you picked because
that seems like such a grand I mean I
understand the high level of what you do
but it's so Grand that I think well like
Oculus was fairly Grand but I kind of
get that you can kind of Tinker in your
garage and come up with a Nifty product
and whatever and like No One's Gonna
like get hurt really and it's like a
pretty simple process hard but simple
Andrew I'm like oh my God I don't even
know where to start I mean I get I've
seen the movie with Jonah Hill where
he's like a war dog or whatever it's
called where he like buys and sell
weapons and I'm like is that what
Android does yeah yeah I'm like is that
what Android does and how on Earth does
even a rich guy who's 28 in his
apartment or his big house come up with
this this is crazy like who do you call
you call like hey uh Hey Brock I was
thinking you know maybe we could try
this like MVP you know what I mean I
don't even know how you start that I
mean it's tough and it is such a big
problem and so unapproachable that very
few people do approach it I mean like
but very big picture
anderol is trying to build the next
major defense prime meaning we were the
prime contract holder we're not a
subcontractor to existing primes like
Lockheed Martin or Raytheon or Northrop
Grumman or Boeing and uh you know I 80
percent of the US defense budget goes to
just a handful of companies these big
primes that just completely dominate the
industry and they get paid on what's
called a Cost Plus basis they get paid
for their time materials fixed
percentage of profit on top which means
that they're incentivized to move slowly
they actually make more money when they
come up with more expensive systems more
money when they sell more of something
more money when it even breaks more
often because they get to sell more
parts for it I mean it's it's a really
bizarre Contracting system that we
created in World War II to basically
take over the U.S war machine or sorry
the US industrial machine turn it into a
war machine because companies like Ford
were saying hey I can't even quote you
what it's going to cost to make a tank
because I've never really you know this
has never really been my business and uh
they said okay fine we'll pay you
whatever it costs and then a fixed
percentage of profit on top to make sure
that you are able to keep running your
business and then unfortunately we just
kept doing that uh even though we were
no longer in an existential War mode and
so in the last 35 years since the end of
the Cold War the government had
completely lost its ability to grow
small defense companies into large
defense accounts companies I mean you
know Samuel Colt went from working in
his tiny garage Workshop to arming the
entire Western world that's that's
that's what we used to be able to do you
could start small and get big if you had
the best stuff but in the last 35 years
there were only two unicorns before
anderol in the defense space and 35
years not just being chosen arbitrarily
it's basically since the end of the Cold
War during the Cold War we did turn
small defense companies into into major
players but since then it's palantir
SpaceX both founded by billionaires and
then nobody else that's it and so it
it's so hard to get in you know Founders
say I have no idea how I could possibly
start a defense company so they don't
start a defense company uh Venture
capitalists say I'm not going to invest
in a defense company there's no examples
of success in the last 35 years less the
billionaires who can do anything I'm
sure they could have done whatever they
wanted with their billions and so the
VCS don't want to invest in it and this
is and then smart employees don't want
to go work at defense startups because
they look at the landscape they say look
this might be a cool lifestyle business
but it's never going to grow to a scale
where the equity that I'm given is a
significant is a significant way to
generate money for me and my family and
so I I said man you know if that's
really what it takes uh it really if it
really does take lots and lots of money
and lots and lots of influence and
really smart people that I'm in a
position to start a company that very
few people are very few Founders have
experience running a multi-billion
dollar company with thousands of
employees Mass manufacturing millions of
pieces of hardware and are and are
willing to give up the Adoration of
their peers in the media like that was
actually probably the most important
factor if I would have just left Oculus
by retiring on my own it would have been
much harder for me to go into an area
like building weapons for the us and our
allies because so many people got so
angry about it you friends that I had
who didn't want to talk to me anymore
investors who said that not only would
we never make money but that what we
were doing was morally reprehensible and
wrong and you know I was trying to
explain to people listen we live in a
world where our major strategic
adversaries are rapidly building
advanced technology that has no peer
here in the United States war machine uh
major conflict is imminent in Asia in
Europe with a lot of our strong allies
and partners and we need to be ready not
just to win those Wars the goal is not
to win Awards to deter a war from
happening in the first place and if we
don't have the tools we need to deter
them then war is inevitable and you guys
probably remember how things were you
know I guess bat you bought five or six
years ago it was very very popular to
believe that we're at the end of history
and that peace is too profitable for
anyone to rock the boat and that that
was the thing that would keep everybody
in line I think that Russia invading
Ukraine finally woke up a lot of people
to realize that history is not over land
borders are not fixed and uh like I mean
look how Wild it is that Europe is still
buying billions of dollars of goods from
Russia even as Russia literally invades
Europe I mean like that's that's how
that's how screwed they are and I think
people people did not see this a few
years ago and I felt I felt a little bit
like a crazy person
um and if I'll ramble on one more thing
you've probably heard me say this before
elsewhere but it could be that you know
your your viewers haven't had heard me
say us I'll say it again
you know we're living in the first time
in U.S history where the most Innovative
powerful and large technology companies
in our country refuse to work with the
military that's never been the case our
most powerful companies have always
understood that they had a
responsibility to Aid with National
Security but now I mean whether you're
talking about Google or in particular
Apple I mean Apple's got 95 of their
Manufacturing in China uh they agreed to
invest they've invested hundreds of
billions of dollars in manufacturing
capacity there they've agreed to invest
a further 275 billion dollars in Chinese
Manufacturing in exchange for being
allowed to operate as an independent
company in China instead of being
nationalized into a joint venture
majority owned by China I mean they they
they're in a position where if they do
anything to upset the Chinese government
the one person in China could sign one
piece of paper that would wipe out the
most powerful company in the entire
world instantly a two trillion dollar
company like they they are not masters
of their own destiny not by any means
and I I guess I want to stress this
because it's never been the case in
history and that had me terrified you
know I five years ago I could see we
were on the precipice of war with
Advanced Powers who had fully suppressed
our most advanced technology companies
through economic tools and you know if I
I don't understand why more people were
not scared by that but I felt like I
couldn't do anything that was more
important than starting Andrew all to
start help solving that problem and
thanks for letting me ramble for so long
on that I know that was a long ramble
but I've got a lot a lot of emotion all
built up inside on it no I mean that's
why we wanted you on is to hear what
you're doing and why and you also
flipped at like the common denominator
with either the prison thing the food
the oil-based Foods or this is that you
kind of looked at it from another angle
and also so maybe flip the incentives to
the cost structure so what you were
saying was let's say with the prison
thing you wanted to be incentivized to
keep people out of prison rather than in
prison for as long as possible exactly
sounds like for Andrew sounds so simple
right yeah it sounds like
it is simple but it's not easy yeah yeah
and well and it sounds like what you ran
into there was the incentive uh for the
local official who you know
um who decides on these things may have
been to have a bigger budget and not a
smaller budget and so you know your
incentives were sort of clashing right
whereas and he doesn't and he doesn't
have to say I'm not buying your thing
because my incentives are wrong you'd be
like oh we've done an assessment of all
the vendors and this one really has a
lot more experience and we don't want to
take a risk on a new vendor it could
literally be that simple he people like
oh but how would they justify the
business model you know it would be so
much better it's like he doesn't have to
like you you can just be like nope I I
too at risk and so what's the business
model with Andrew because you're not
doing Cost Plus you're doing something
else and
um
that company I mean we work the way it's
not even a revolutionary business model
it's the way every tech company works
you use your own money you build a
product you make it work and then you go
to customers and you sell it to them and
that is a very hard thing to do in the
defense space but we've basically bet
that we will be able to pick the right
things to work on that will be able to
find the right Partners in government to
help tell us what we should be investing
our own money in ahead of time and that
in the end when it works that we'll be
able to sell most of the time to the
government now there will be times where
we get screwed there will be times where
we don't build things that work and uh
you know and it's our own money that
we've earned instead of taxpayers but on
the whole we're very incentivized to be
efficient we don't wanted things to drag
out we don't want to drag it out to be a
10-year r d program on a Cost Plus basis
when we can get it done in six months
with some really really smart ideas and
so we've got the right incentives and
we're basically out there trying to
convince the Department of Defense and
politicians that this is the way that
all defense companies should be working
everyone should live in fear looking
over their own shoulder knowing that if
they fail that they're the ones who are
going to get screwed not taxpayers so
when you get a contract that's like we
got a 900 million dollar contract that's
after you've already produced the
product and they're basically just
agreeing to buy the goods at that point
is that what that means in your case
yeah I mean when we recently just won a
billion dollar contract with Socom
Special Operations uh command uh to do
all of their counter drone work so
basically protecting like building the
hardware and software that is defending
them from uh from drones that are
attacking their installations and
positions and we started working on our
counter drone system using all of our
own money years and years ago before we
had any customer we just we started
building the hardware and the software
building our interceptors building our
Jammers and uh then we it was after we
invested a ton of our own money and
proved that this was the right way to
solve the problem that we were able to
go and actually there was a full
competition for who they were going to
select for this and they did basically a
shoot off between all these different
companies and some of the companies that
we beat were actually getting paid by
the government to develop their systems
using government money but we had
invested quite a bit more money and
moved much faster and there were
literally contractors that were
complaining saying this isn't fair we
have to compete with Andrew and they've
been investing their own money for years
how could we possibly be expected to
compete when the government's only given
us you know tens of millions of dollars
over the course of the last two years
and I I'm like guys like of course this
is how it works like you could have won
if you had spent your own money if you
had spent your own money for five years
you probably would be able to compete
with us on an even playing field but you
can't take no risk and expect all of the
reward and we spent a lot less than
these companies developing much better
capabilities because we have the right
incentives so you're you're I think
you're 30 years old so you're we're all
about the same age you're sitting there
with just turned 30 a few weeks ago well
happy birthday you're sitting there in a
Hawaiian T-shirt with a goatee I
you're probably the type of dude who
walks around barefooted all the time and
you're talking about Cosplay and yet you
just said we just won a billion dollar
contract from the government how do you
work up like the the huevos the
confidence to think like
I'm gonna go in against all these
gray-haired suits and like they're gonna
the government's eventually gonna take
me seriously and I'm gonna sell this uh
sell this thing I mean or do you have
people selling on your behalf but like
that that's just a reach for me to
understand
some people think that I should that I
should dress differently and try to kind
of you know appeal to the government
sensibilities and like you know I should
be addressing in a suit and I should be
very very straight laced and you'll be
very very serious all the time but I
think that one of the most important
things that Andrew is doing is not just
Building Technology ourselves but it's
inspiring other companies to work in
defense not just company like inspiring
companies that aren't in defense to
Pivot and defense and inspiring people
to start new defense companies and if
they see me like becoming a boring guy
who's who's you know has to make himself
super lame to sell to the government
that's not a lifestyle that they're
going to want to lead you know and so we
need to show that they can be successful
and show them that it's that it's going
to be fun now I also want to keep uh
wearing flip-flops in the Hawaiian
shirts so maybe I'm maybe this is just
you know post facto justification no I'm
on board
everyone a disservice if I were to
change yeah I think it's working now you
know we uh the podcast is all about the
future we're always brainstorming ideas
opportunities uh but none of that
matters if there's not really a future
if this is about to become World War III
and there's nukes flying everywhere so
you're kind of uh a lot more in the loop
than any guest that we've ever had on
this
what's gonna happen here is this what
are the odds of like you know this sort
of Ukraine Russia conflict breaking out
into something a lot more serious and
like you know
is there going to be a nuclear weapon
you know in our
near future so I mean it's very hard to
predict there's people who are better at
this than me like what I always tell
people is like our role is to build the
tools and then you have to trust in
democracy to deploy them correctly and
people think oh you know when would you
stop supplying weapons to you you
Ukraine and you know is there a point
where you'd be too you know where you
where you think that we should or you
would make sure that you're not part of
a nuclear escalation and I say listen if
you believe in democracy at all then you
should not want U.S foreign policy to be
dictated by the ever-changing whims of
Technology Executives like what an
extraordinarily dangerous precedent to
set that you know you'll build weapons
for the people you are politically
aligned with and then you'll suddenly
drop it uh despite the uh like what it
really is is I will sell to the people
of the U.S state department and the
usdod want me to like if that that
because they have information that I
don't they have uh intelligence that I
do not and I cannot second guess that
and say oh you know I I would stop
supplying if I I thought there was this
level of escalation but with that out of
the way I think that we are going to see
a tactical nuke get used uh and for
people who are not familiar with the
difference tactical nuclear weapons are
designed for tactical use as part of a
battle uh for basically conventional
Warfare tactics so blowing up uh you're
blowing up uh an Armored Division or
taking out a wing of bombers or maybe
even destroying an Airfield strategic
nuclear weapons are used to deter Mass
nuclear exchange and to engage in you
know strategic level annihilation of
cities and the like uh the United States
disassembled all of our tactical nuclear
weapons a long time ago we decided that
our wart Doctrine did not allow for
tactical nukes nukes are only something
you use at a strategic level to deter
other people from using them against you
that is not the case for Russia Russia
has tactical nuclear weapons if they
train to use them they it is part of
their doctrine that they will use them
in conventional conflict and they are at
like even just having that in their
Doctrine shows that to some degree they
are willing to bet that the United
States and nobody else would respond
with strategic nuclear weapons in
response to use of a tactical nuclear
weapon and uh if some people say oh even
saying that they'll use a nuke is akin
to supporting Russia and saying we
shouldn't support Ukraine I'm not saying
that at all I think actually appeasement
has the the longer that they're actually
the greater risk I mean if you can show
if you show to the world that if you
show to a world that even the threat of
small-scale tactical nuclear weapons is
enough to deter
any kind of intervention in any kind of
con in any kind of conventional Warfare
you actually hugely incentivize the
nations of the world to obtain their own
tactical nuclear weapons like you you
you don't really actually want the
calculus to tip that way where countries
look and say wow all Russia had to do
was threaten to use their tactical nukes
and then they were allowed to operate
with impunity in a conventional Invasion
and nobody was willing to stop to do
anything about it or even stop buying
their exports like that that's the that
that would be a very very bad precedent
to set even Beyond this war and so for
that reason I I think this is a little
contrarian and not everyone agrees but I
think that the odds of a tactical
nuclear weapon are very high it will not
be used on the United States it will not
be used on a NATO Ally it'll probably be
a tactical nuclear weapon used to strike
some inarguably military Target like it
probably they're not gonna they're not
gonna nuke cave uh it's much more likely
that it would be a port or a you know or
an errand relation or something like
that and the reason I like to talk about
this is I want people to get comfortable
with this because there's this idea that
you know you use it you use it you use a
nuclear weapon and all of a sudden
you're in World War Three uh I think
that's actually probably the wrong the
wrong way to look at it because if you
do that you're tacitly admitting that
tactical nuclear weapons deserve a
strategic nuclear level response and if
you set that up as you know the nice
lubricated path we all slide down yeah
things are really bad this sounds like
selfish and trite but I I think I it's
important to me and I bet it's important
to a lot of people what does that mean
for me uh a a wealthy American with
money in the stock market who lives in a
nice life like does that mean that like
uh inflation's Gonna Get huge does that
mean that my investments are going to go
down does that mean that like people I
know I don't know anyone in Ukraine so I
care about them but like does that mean
people I know are gonna get hurt what
does that mean for me
it's a fair question you know I'm in a
different position I know I know people
who are from Ukraine I know people are
in Ukraine so for me it also it does get
a little bit personal and we have
employees here who are who are deeply
deeply
you know involved in one way or another
with the people of Ukraine
um but I think mostly you need to boil
it now not to necessarily A Ukraine
specific question but the broader
geopolitical question
is the United States the world police
are we going to help our allies and to
what extent and I'm not saying that
necessarily means that we need to throw
ourselves into World War III over every
conflict but we do need to very
carefully weigh like what what will
happen in Taiwan if we completely pull
that like there's a million ways to
tackle this so I'm not trying to set up
a straw man here but I'll throw out one
that is actually very popular with
certain politicians they say we should
completely pull out we should not engage
this is not our problem let the let the
ex-soviet guys duke it out they can do
whatever they want well one there the
first issue is uh our European allies
are going to be in pretty bad shape if
they have Russia right on their border
able to move deep deep deep into Europe
without any kind of buffer more
importantly what do you think China is
going to do if they see that that's the
United States attitude they say wow like
there there is a price they will not pay
uh there is there is a certain level
they are not willing to get engaged at
if we can raise the cost above that
level then they will make the short-term
decision to not get engaged age that's
very dangerous for Taiwan which is in
turn very dangerous for semiconductors
and for our entire economy like I If
Taiwan actually gets invaded by China
you could see a 30 or 40 percent drop in
the stock market beyond what we've
already seen like that's not even that's
not even a that's not even a a crazy
assumption that's like a pretty well
backed up by all of the the boring
establishment economics guys uh
prediction so that that the way that I
see it is your question why should I
care
because if we want to maintain
credibility as a player that can deter
Wars not just win Wars then we have to
take actions that maintain our
credibility there if we if if we were to
say the ultimate version of the screws
you're on your own world we're all and
we're going to do our own thing uh we're
going to get screwed by that very very
quickly and so there's something between
zero engagement and you know D-Day 2.0
that we have to do this is a great uh
Palmer where can people find you if they
want to go work at Andrew or you know
read more your stuff your blog your
Twitter where should people follow you
or find you if they like this
oh man well my my my my handle my handle
across social media is Palmer Tech
um but on you can find me on Twitter
under the handle Palmer lucky uh there's
my website palmerlucky.com the number
one Palmer lucky blog on the internet
and I'm covered is also press sites I'm
coming for you oh well hey mine's
wordpressed too great tool yeah someone
just tell me about Palmer lucky69.com
he's is this new project he's working on
yeah it's got a lot of Promise
oh man I gotta check this out that
sounds right up my alley oh wait wait do
you want to rip a WWE style promo at
Jason calicanis who's coming after you
he's challenges you to a fight why would
you challenge a guy who builds weapons
for a living to a fight I don't
understand this but if you want to rip a
WWE style promo this is this is the
place there are 100 000 entrepreneurs
ready to back you here if you can get
them on your side I mean maybe this is
because I all like look I'm I don't know
if you can tell like I'm actually a
pretty big guy like I weigh about 250
pounds I'm six feet tall
um like I it's kind of
I understand the mechanics of fighting
well enough and I've done enough of it
recreationally to understand that it's
unlikely that somebody who's like you
know five foot five and 140 pounds is
gonna it's good it's gonna have a a good
shot but I the thing is I don't I'm not
a I'm not a physical violence kind of
guy I I think it's weird to be like oh
yeah you know you you you you you you
you don't like me well I could beat you
in in hand-to-hand combat it's like well
I mean maybe but like your ideas are
still bad
it doesn't it one does one doesn't solve
the other
um so no I unfortunately I don't think
I'll be throwing I don't think I'll be
throwing down the gauntlet beyond beyond
noting that just you
statistically speaking you know if you
just look at the fights between people
of of one bulk versus another yeah
there's a there's a clear Trend yeah
dude is this the most Silicon Valley
call out ever
I know the mechanics of fighting
physics is on my side
yeah you know I mean for people who are
listening and don't know the very short
version is Jason calacanus said a bunch
of really awful stuff about me for for
years starting back in 2016 what you
know when he said that I'm a terrible
person that I don't care about my family
or my I think he said Palmer lucky is a
complete who doesn't care about
his employees or his families or his
friends uh and then you know Palmer's an
idiot he's a Zuckerberg should
fire him get rid of him what a useless
waste of space then not get fired he
celebrates it over and over oh man I'm
so glad that fire Obama what a terrible
loser et cetera et cetera anyway then he
just didn't then he just didn't talk to
me for years never reached out and then
he invites me to go speak it uh on his
podcast and then at his conference so I
went there and I I basically just told
people I'm like I can't believe Jason
invited me it's only because I've clawed
my way back to having a second unicorn
before the age of 30. like this guy
treated me like total garbage for years
he's never apologized he spread a bunch
of lot even insult Society spread a
bunch of lies about me and then uh at
the com and I said hey here look at all
this he said about me like yeah you
had like a he was like a snapback it was
amazing yeah
and then uh and I did that at the end of
my talk about you know basically the
future of conflict and particularly the
war in Ukraine and then at the
conference he said that he was sorry if
he said anything that offended me but
then when he put my video up he said
actually I take it back everything that
I said was accurate and I don't regret
exactly what I said about him
um and I was and so now people people
keep hitting him up like you guys need
to bury the hatchet you know me in the
middle I'm like I didn't do anything
like you you can't meet him like you're
right maybe maybe I don't care about my
family but you know we can admit I I
care about my friends let's meet in the
middle it's like no no that's not gonna
happen uh anyway so now now Jason's
saying that he can that he can beat me
up uh on and he's uh and and you know
look maybe he could but the odds don't
seem in his face I do think he trains
Jiu Jitsu so that you know he does have
that going for him if I recall correctly
hey you know I I I did I did Karate one
time when I was a kid
well now it's been wild for me because I
mean my whole career I've been uh my my
whole career I've been a whiz kid you
know it's like the Palmer lucky value
proposition is wow look at that guy he's
improbably successful given his age and
now it's just look at Palmer he's yeah
he's successful I guess you know 30.
yeah
I don't really want to agree with you
anything and also uh you know I find
Jason very entertaining I like uh I
don't know him personally very well or
anything but but you know he's
entertaining but he also I think was
totally wrong in this uh circumstance I
remember when I first heard him say all
that I looked up I was like man
Palmer must have well actually called
you Parker lucky I was like oh man this
Parker lucky that's right this Plucky
little guy must have done something
really messed up and then I saw what was
actually done and I saw the coverage and
I was like oh he he donated ten thousand
dollars to you know like this thing or
whatever you know you you were right
whatever
but Jason is out there saying he says
Palmer's paying Trump supporters
yeah yeah yeah yeah extreme Terror
trolling he said not quite violent but
close to it and he's posting
anti-semitic memes and misogynistic hate
attacks it's like dude it was nine
thousand dollars to a billboard like
you've you've given a heck of a lot more
yet to spicier political stuff than that
you know
in a political cause or a political
donation it's nothing like you know I
think that's one of the big one of the
big hypocrisies it's not as mainstream
as you can get the hypocrisy of Silicon
Valley is like it's all about
open-mindedness unless you disagree with
us unless you unless you believe in the
thing I don't agree with then how dare
you believe that you know how dare you
support that candidate I don't like how
dare you you know that half the country
you know votes for whatever it's one of
the great hypocrisy so so it's so
foreign to me too because I mean like
one of my best friends is a socialist I
like we we very we strongly disagree
politically but like running Oculus I
was never I I like I had my political
beliefs but they were like one percent
of my time I'm thinking 99 of it was on
VR in my company and it's it's it's
actually very funny where like I there
was a story recently said you know
Palmer Palmer lucky you know uh a very
outspoken Republican I'm like I mean
I've literally tweeted about politics
two times in eight years like yeah I'm
not outspoken by any means but to them
it means like oh there was this story
years ago where he privately donated not
using his name and that means he's an
outspoken Republican and you know
imagine if people were like Mark
Zuckerberg outspoken Democrat does X
like yeah
autocorrect would be like you must have
made a mistake the sentence doesn't get
typed
yeah I mean that but that that's the
best part about anderol is that like I
have my political beliefs like our CEO
Brian shib uh he's he's very much a
Democrat uh and we have a huge mix of
people at anderol across the entire
political spectrum and what we've done
is said listen we we might not agree on
everything but we agree on the
importance of National Security we agree
that the United States needs to have the
tools that deter Russia China and other
aggressors from getting into fights with
our partners and allies and we agree
that we can save taxpayers hundreds of
billions of dollars a year while we make
tens of billions of dollars a year and
if we agree on those things we need to
put aside the differences and you'll
focus on what's what's the same and I
think that's been a really healthy
company company culture like a lot of
other companies you know they'll they
want to take one political side of the
other and we've been very clear no we
are not a politically uh oriented
company we are a mission oriented
company and to the extent like if a
republican does something that's bad for
our mission we're going to push back on
it if a Democrat does something that is
bad for our mission we're going to push
back on it but it needs to be about our
ability to you know defend the West not
our you know our personal opinions on
how the country should be run so that's
that's I I highly encourage people to
set that to set that tone when they're
starting their own companies if you want
to be able to attract people from all
over the country all over the world of
all different political Persuasions
because if you pick a side you're you're
alienating huge swaths of people not
just the people who disagree with you
but also people who don't want to be at
a company that's partisan and might not
even care one way or the other I I know
there's a lot of people here like look I
don't I don't even really have a strong
political set of beliefs but I do know I
don't want to work in a place where
that's the thing that drives all our
decisions you're like oh we got the
office socialist just walking around
giving away snacks it's awesome it's
great you need a diverse workplace like
this this is awesome dude you're awesome
man I'm that's right I'm so pumped that
uh you came on uh this is this is this
has been amazing I would love you to
come on again well hey I have to bring
up one more thing I have to bring up one
more thing I so I I get a chance to
bring something up fine good I I we we
we we we we got we got to talk about the
the Tweet you made where you said that
uh there's no way that there's any
billionaires out there that actually fly
coach and don't fly right oh yes good
you have got a good Henry do you do you
fly coach oh you you do fly coach you
said that you're an idiot what are you
doing Jacob was right
I mean so so I I the reason I wanted to
chat about it is because yeah I think I
responded I told you like hey you're
wrong like I I actually do I don't fly
private I do fly coach uh for me it's
it's a it's a it's a reason thing where
uh we we with exceptions for long-term
like long long international travel we
only cover coach travel for our
employees it's like look it's only a few
hours like it is a very bad use of
company money for us to be buying
business or first class for people
because we have so much travel at the
company
we could easily spend a very serious
fraction of our of our of our resources
on just people traveling in slightly
better seats and so and it's especially
especially bad when it's like oh am I
really going to pay you to like you know
fly business class for three hours to a
place where you're then going to like
sweat it out in the desert for for a
week like you know it's only yeah so you
and your coach seats better than the
desert you and your wife or your
girlfriend or whatever if you're going
to Europe you're going to fly coach even
when I use my own money I fly coach and
people say well why don't you just fly
first class why don't you fly business
and here's why because I expect my
employees to fly coach and even like yes
I have a lot of money but it's if I
don't also do it it feels like I'm out
of touch or I don't know what it's like
or you know oh it's easy for you to say
that we should fly coach because you
don't have to do it because you happen
to have a bunch of money and so for for
me a lot of is setting example like look
it's not actually that bad I am willing
to do it even when I pay for my own
travel uh because that's just not that
bad and so don't you have like people
who want to like kill you or like hurt
you I mean aren't you like uh I mean
like like you've got the whole
anti-trump crowd who sees you you and
they're like go f yourself and then now
you're like dealing with Lockheed Martin
and stuff surely they want to like
kneecap you you got your your I don't
know what you're talking about Fanatics
yeah you got Jason
like something's gonna happen you know
what I mean like surely like there's
like some type of security risk also I
maybe you have life insurance or
something like that if they're gonna
insure you I'd be like dog you're doing
you're you gotta have this a security
person with you or you gotta like have
someone with you like surely there's
some type of security risk where you got
to think like Beyond just like
hey guys I'm in solitude with you on
this flight like I get it like I mean
surely there's some type of like you're
totally you're you're you're totally
right and I I mean it depends on the
trip where the trip is and what I'm
doing and like I I make sure to keep
myself safe
um and I probably don't want to get into
the specifics because you know like you
said there's people out there who who
are not fans of me and like you you
mentioned you know Jason calacanus and
the Trump people but like what about the
Mexican cartels that we've cost hundreds
of Millions of dollars in drug trade
what about you know all the people who
have been foiled in attacks on U.S
military forces because of our stuff and
you know like there's actually a long
list of people who are more who are
scarier than Jason calcanus if you can
believe it
um but uh yeah look you you you're right
that to some degree that that's a worry
but I also think that in general if
someone's going to come to kill me it's
probably going to be a place where they
know I'm going to be and there's there's
actually much higher like to me the
high-risk place is actually not on a on
a flight in the secure Zone yeah it's
not on Southwest in the secure zone of
an airport uh like there's actually it's
actually probably more likely to be the
restaurants I go to too much
um but anyway I guess I want to explain
that's why I do it if I'm gonna ask my
employees to do it I need to do it too
even when it's my own money even when
it's my own cost because otherwise you
are like you but you become an out it's
not just that I appear out of touch I
would literally be out of touch maybe
one day coach gets so bad that I tell
everyone guys you know what I hear you
we're all all go in business now but I
think I think today is not that day
you're crazy I've agreed with everything
you've said except for that you are
crazy
yeah no I'm actually glad you said this
because I was feeling like man this
guy's great he's funny he's smart he's
just really big thinker I'm glad you
have something you're totally wrong
about it makes me feel so much better in
this interview that's a great service
you did for everybody here by just
having this absolute nonsense policy for
yourself you know like if I go get you
if I'm the guy who flies to go get that
billion dollar contract and I'm flying
back you know in the in the c-zone of
Southwest
I'm riding the next day at work I'm
telling you I love the I love the back
of the plane on the window no but nobody
bothers you you can get on you can let
everybody get off the plane before you
do you don't have to fight anybody you
just you know let everyone know what
what is that I gotta throw this in my
great my grandpa was a pilot for United
Airlines for over 40 years and so I also
grew up around commercial airlines and
so this might be another thing like to
me there is a certain Romanticism to
like Mass Market Mass available air
travel like what an incredible thing and
we did it America did it we figured out
how to make it economically viable and
we build everyone else's airplanes like
it is an American thing and so I even
when you're on everyone else's planes
they're mostly made by Americans and the
ones that are made by Europeans were
made with American Technology so I I uh
look I I also like
I think feet are gross you're into coach
I think coaches grossful yeah to each
their own and I think we'll leave it at
that agree to disagree with their own no
look I uh I disagree with that opinion
but I respect it like hell and I respect
you you're the best man I would love for
you to come on if you want like in a few
weeks a few months whenever and talk
some more about ideas you're uh I'm a
fan of yours so this feels really cool
that you're here maybe we thank you I
appreciate that this this has been a lot
of fun we covered some good ground today
yes and maybe we've suckered you into
becoming friends with us so if you ever
want you could DS DM us on Twitter we
come up hobies who knows I don't know
maybe we'll invite each other over and
hang out you can show us a thing or two
I don't know we'll see what happens but
uh this has been awesome come on come on
come on down anytime all right right
sweet thank you so much all right see
you guys later
[Music]